bismillah dama de la salaam-alaikum hey
guys Ramadan is right around the corner
it's a spiritual boot camp it's coming
the perfect time to really recharge the
hearts and to inshallah God willing come
out spiritually clean and at the end of
it to really cleanse the heart and the
soul if you've been living up until now
damaging and corrupting the soul there's
no time like the present time or the
main sank panic forces the shayateen The
Devil's will be locked up during Ramadan
making it so much easier for you for us
to repair the damage that has been done
to the heart to the soul like no other
way know the system as the perfect
system sent by the divine Ramadan
that's that spiritual boot camp like no
other
remember people can have the most money
be a part of the greatest social circles
have everything you want and desire of
this world of this dunya but at the end
the reality is that you're going to die
and leave it all behind and running away
from this reality won't make what
happens next after this world any better
what often should be a great reminder
and a motivation for us to take this
matter to take the matter serious and to
sincerely research for find and really
live our true purpose in life is when we
see people meeting the reality of death
for example recently so many people have
been visited by medical mult
angel of death a few of them you might
know and the only reason that I
mentioned these people in particular
them in particular is because if I
mentioned people who you really didn't
know you you know who they were it would
have the same effect usually as when you
see someone whom you recognize like for
example Emmy award-winning Bill Paxton
superstar he just passed Hollywood star
Miguel fervour who's the cousin of
George Clooney Chris Cornell frontman in
the rock bands who had all the material
worldly things remember this really
think this is deep it's profound he had
everything they but was obviously
spiritually empty and committed suicide
because there is no one that if your
heart if that person's heart is
connected your heart is found and
connected to your creator that would
ever fall into such great despair and
pain the pressure has to be in such deep
deep profound pain to take their own
life just remember those innocent men
women and children who have lost
everything but they got bombs falling on
top literally from the left and from the
right and places like Syria families
experiencing famine in places like
Somalia and Africa dying from no food
and water but they still they still have
a strong connection to the Creator
losing no hope so they find solace
contentment and peace in their hearts
where others who are trying to find
happiness in partying day and night
buying every material thing they desire
eating the best of foods driving the
best of cars wearing the fanciest
clothes but they can't stop complaining
about the smallest most sometimes the
most even significant things and have no
true peace in their hearts nor
experience the richness of contentment
in the heart the void spiritual void sad
and empty inside remember Eddie Murphy
well his brother also recently just died
Charlie Murphy also never forget that
those who have helped spread evil and
corruption on the earth don't worry God
Almighty Allah
has a place for them because you can't
live forever even if you're the CEO of
Fox News like Roger Ellis or its host
Alan combs or even those at the very top
who thought they were running the world
the riches of rich having billions when
people only had millions and they
thought they would never be called back
to the king of kings allah the almighty
god almighty people can live up to the
ripe old age of 101 and have acquired
everything in this world and not
escaping death it's your chance now
during Ramadan to set things right
between you and your maker to leave off
with the evil of the old and to start
fresh by implementing all the good
things your Creator has told you to do
the first a first is to turn your entire
self to him alone I mean it's something
very basic simple but we overlook these
basics we jump here and jump down we
forget that this is what it starts with
worshiping the Creator and not his
creation pure monotheism Touhey and
establishing the salah/the prayer in
your life that's the connection with
your Lord step-by-step learning more
about the one who brought you into
existence and as you learn you'll grow
obviously you'll grow in knowledge and
you'll grow in love because naturally
the more you know about the one who
created you the more you're going to
love him and the more you grow in this
love you're going to go and wanting to
serve and please your Creator
implementing step by step everything he
told you to do that will only bring good
into your life and leaving off
everything he told you to abstain from
as for anything that we're told to us
staying from its harmful harmful for
yourself harmful for Humanity and there
is great
Danette I leave you my brothers and
sisters I leave you with a little
homework to do and most of this is new
to you but your heart recognizes what's
being said and that you sincerely you
start every day by asking the reality
the one up above the one who brought you
into existence and put you into this
world whose testing you brought you into
this world to test you to examine you
ask him alone the Creator to guide you
and to open your heart to the truth
because when death comes we'll be too
late there's no coming back to take to
retake the test that you're in already
you can't take it again and after here
it's either the reward of Jena paradise
or consequences
we understand consequences and Jesus
talked about this Abraham Moses all of
them but the consequence is Jahannam the
Hellfire it's nothing new it's not a new
message it's the same way of life from
the beginning the first man Adam was
told to submit to the creator and then
all the other messengers that came after
him some people obeyed some people
didn't and those who obeyed they were
the Muslims those who submit to
themselves that's what a Muslim is one
who submits himself peacefully to the
Creator alone doesn't worship a human
being
saints angels money material things dead
people in the ground
no only the one up above creation the
one who created creation and again it's
the same message Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon all of them he was
just the final and the last messenger
sent to mankind
thank you guys start with this little
homework because when you seek you shall
find if you're not seeking how you're
going to find so we talked about just to
recap this blessed month of Ramadan is
perfect opportunity to recharge the Iman
to leave off the evil from old and start
implementing all the good things that
the creator's told us to do we all make
mistakes all of us but now is the time
to really enjoy and to benefit from the
spiritual blessings of the spiritual
bootcamp the Ramadan and to take heed
Kunlun F's in the concealer mold every
soul will taste death and I'll give you
some examples of people whom you grew up
watching they're gone they're dead
that's it no coming back and just like
you cannot comprehend that you are once
in your mother's womb and now you're in
this this hole this huge world you're in
it is I'm almost to tell you in while
you were in that room that you're coming
out to this you couldn't comprehend that
nor can you comprehend that point in
your life but not everything we can't
comprehend is not going to be a reality
or was not a reality just like us
leaving this world we feel like we're
going to live forever but that is
because we're either going to believe
forever in general or Jahannam of course
obviously those who have died on pure
monotheism they committed some some sins
there will be some will be purify may
Allah protect us we don't want to spend
a second in the Hellfire not a second so
we gave an example of those who were on
the earth now they're dead and they many
had all the material things and now did
that benefit them no it didn't and the
simple homework is to what to beseech to
earnestly sincerely genuinely as you're
looking into this if this is new to some
people and you see all it's so confusing
which religion is from God it has to fit
with what's in your heart the innate
disposition you've been created with and
when I tell you worship the Creator
alone not his creation you know that
makes sense and the one who brought that
message was Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him and that was confirming the
message from Jesus Moses Abraham and all
the preceding messengers it just makes
sense and when you're asking the owner
of all of this to guide you to
facilitate a way why would he leave you
on your own so start with that homework
asking the Creator up above to guide
your heart
may Allah the Almighty bless you and may
you have a wonderful and blessed Ramadan
I saw I'll make them greetings a peace